Bill Maher said FBI rate might have
saved martyr Trump from losing to the
santis and GOP Primary calling Trump the
luckiest man in the world his fortune
was finally falling the big lie was
finally losing momentum DeSantis was
beating him in the polls you know how he
hates this more than anybody the
scientist I had this one in the back and
now I got a run against President martyr
Bill Maher says as he impersonates
DeSantis Mar argued that the raid was
saving Trump politically because it has
caused all the Republicans to Rally
around Trump so did this help or hurt
Trump Adam
look I
Trump's ceiling is 42 whatever the
number is the the bigger question number
one I don't I don't think that DeSantis
would beat Trump in a primary in a
general I've been very clear I'd much
rather have a DeSantis rather than a
trump I think the question that we all
need to ask ourselves is whether you're
a trump supporter or not let's pretend
I'm a trump supporter for a second I'm
gonna put on my trumpet
these things are not going to stop with
Trump again
pretend I'm a trump supporter how many
like look at the track record Russia
Russia Russia impeachment number one
impeachment number two quid pro quo
January 6 Insurrection Mar-A-Lago what
gives you the idea that if there's four
more years of trump this nonsense isn't
going to go on again if I'm on team
Trump and I'm saying I love Trump he's
the best president ever he's making
America great again that's amazing at
some point the exhaustion and the
fatigue as I said it's like holy [ __ ]
everywhere this guy goes there's another
drama whether it's shooting himself in
the foot or whether it's basically the
leftist agenda that's coming after him
but the reality is every few months
there's another Trump Saga you're
talking about Hunter Biden again get
back to Trump
I don't know what that means however
it's so listen to what you just said
it's so exhausting with Trump again
pretend I'm on team Trump here
every three months every six months
there's gonna be another political drama
that you're gonna have to run through
but you say that it's gonna as though
these are Trump's doings I'm just again
pretending I'm a trump fan yeah this is
the reality there's another impeachment
coming down the road there's another but
if you're pretending it's another drama
that's not what they're saying the Trump
fans are not saying that no I'm just
they're saying that's all the facts here
Tom no hang on everything I just said
was not my opinion you hang on
everything I've just said oh is exactly
what happened did he not go through two
impeachments
let me ask you a question you're not
saying whether those things were true or
not all you're saying is a trump brings
a lot of drama that's what you're
thinking so you're not you're saying
Russia was a hoax you're saying the
impeachment didn't really do anything
that just happened is just expect more
of it okay so then so okay so then let's
process also this is a trump a trump
person your premises a trump person is
going to say gosh this is all these
things are too fatigue digging that's
not what the the that's not what Maga
said Maga says all these things voiced
it against our hero they're not saying
I'm fatigued so that's my point my my
simple point there you hang on right was
that the Trump fans are not saying
they're fatigued they are saying they're
fatigue they're tired you know it's the
liberal establishment trying to attack
their boy I just go go for it I disagree
with that
I think there is some fatigue in the
mega movement
and there has to be and it's gone
unrightfully so
um I think the response to people
weaponizing the truth and manipulating
and using it to try and bully you into
emotional fatigue should be
opposed vehemently you should never give
way to somebody who's marked you out and
said if we just keep lying enough this
personal ride off into the sunset we
won't have to worry about it that's how
you lose a country that's how you lose a
country in Grand fashion which we have
but I do see as a rising voice in the
America first movement in the Maga
movement in that Circle that many people
are
criticizing Trump not necessarily for
the rightful criticisms that there are
but more along the lines of these
contextual well if he runs again then we
have to look forward to more of this and
it would just be better if DeSantis had
his day and you know my my concept of it
again going back to earlier is
um the greater scope of it is the people
who we oppose the forces that are
coalesced against us spiritually
politically ideology ideologically and
emotionally whatever
um they are opposed to
Donald Trump at a deep level it's not
him he's just his current scapegoat if
DeSantis wins and he got in there would
be no way that they would look more
favorably on DeSantis and not try the
same tax tactics on him unless he
abandoned an America First Position
which he might and and and I might I'm
on team Trump
but I'm going to say something that the
Maga movement might not like right now
um
this is all moral hazard
to what I was telling you earlier when
you
don't tell the truth when it's time to
tell the truth and fight and die for the
things you believe in when it's time to
that it comes back to bite you and we
talked about this 10 20 50 hypothetical
time Horizon well Donald Trump's time
Horizon on moral hazard just just
knocked on his door right now and it was
only a few years later because what he
didn't do as America first as he was as
trade as he was as immigration as he was
as anti-liberalism Church of lgbtq
drained the swamp as he was
he didn't deconstruct the administrative
state
he didn't gut the intelligence
communities and he should have
and he had the he had the juice to at
least lie before
but even he in a flawed Manner and again
I'd support him running as the as the
candidate in 24
for the GOP and become a president I
think the country needs him right now
but we don't want an echo chamber in the
American first movement
that any Maga supporters who want an
echo chamber and don't like anybody who
has any criticism of trump they're not
real Americans they're cucks
he should have deconstructed the
administrative State he should have
fought harder to deconstruct the the
security state
but he didn't because he likes his
security
and and in trying to move these
institutions we all fall victim to our
own personal relevance to him
and this is the moral hazard he actually
believed that the military was behind
him when he was a president and then our
guy Millie was talking to China behind
his back he was never with him right
Barr betrayed him all of these people
that were in these positions betrayed
him and he and and he actually was
pretty moderate like I can tell from the
things that he went for and the things
that he said and the people who I know
were behind him and the spirit of what
he really was trying to do he was
moderate on and he tried to do that to
appeal to a Centrist uh uh you know a
more Centrist
spirit and it bit him in the butt so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]